This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. So often, when we're thinking about who we are and what we want from our lives, we think about the choices that we make. How do we get from point A to point B? What steps can we take to improve our careers, our relationships, our personal health? As we ponder these questions, it can be tempting to assume that all we need is the right blueprint, and we can build the exact life that we want. But the choices we make are only part of the equation.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们经常在思考自己是谁、生活中想要什么时，会想到我们所做的选择。我们如何从A点到达B点？我们可以采取哪些步骤来改善职业、人际关系和个人健康？当我们思考这些问题时，很容易认为我们只需要一份正确的蓝图，就能构建出我们想要的生活。但我们所做的选择只是等式的一部分。
So often, the trajectory of our lives is shaped by moments when our decision-making goes haywire, when we act in ways that feel completely out of character. What are we to make of these moments? What do they tell us about our inner selves? This week on Hidden Brain, as part of our annual U2.0 series, we bring you a favorite episode about certain situations that cause us to become strangers to ourselves. I definitely didn't maintain cool and calm.
通常，我们的人生轨迹是由那些决策失控、行为举止完全不像平时的自己的时刻所塑造的。我们该如何看待这些时刻？它们向我们揭示了怎样的内心世界？本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，作为我们年度“U2.0”系列的一部分，我们将为您带来一期备受喜爱的节目，探讨那些让我们变得连自己都不认识的特定情境。我当时绝对没有保持冷静。
My entire body froze. I was just an absolute, blubbering mask. I became filled with anger and I just kind of lost it. And we look at the deep psychological mystery that occurs during these moments. No matter how many times we discover the stranger's living inside us, the next time, always catches us by surprise. Quick heads up, this episode contains stories about sex, sex work, and sexual harassment. Morgan Smiley has been performing with an improv comedy troupe since she was in college. After dozens of performances, she's learned that you need more than a creative mind to
我的整个身体僵住了。我完全成了一个只会哭泣的傻瓜。我充满了愤怒，整个人几乎崩溃了。我们审视了在这些时刻发生的深层心理奥秘。无论我们多少次发现内心住着一个陌生人，下一次，它总会让我们措手不及。温馨提示，本集包含有关性、性工作和性骚扰的故事。摩根·斯迈利从大学起就一直在参加即兴喜剧团的表演。经过几十场演出，她明白要让观众发笑，需要的不仅仅是创造力。
get the audience laughing. You also need to be a good listener. That means not just hearing what people say. You have to pick up on everything that surrounds the words. Like, let's say I came out and instead of saying happy birthday, like with a happy face, I can be like happy birthday and clearly that means that I'm upset. And then we go from there like, why am I mad at them? Is it that when it was my birthday last time, they treated me like garbage,
你还需要做一个好的倾听者。这意味着不仅仅是听别人说了什么。你必须捕捉到言语之外的一切。比如，假设我走出来，没有面带微笑地说“生日快乐”，而是说“生日快乐”，这显然意味着我很不高兴。然后我们从那里开始，比如，我为什么对他们生气？是因为上次我过生日时，他们像对待垃圾一样对待我吗？
things like that. Morgan prides herself on being able to pick up on subtext, on being able to read between the lines, behind the lines. When she does that well, she can hear the results immediately. When you get the laugh, you just like such a self-esteem boost. It's like instant validation. And instantly exhilarating. That's how she felt at a recent show. There's one thing I did. I was like a slug on stage.
诸如此类的事情。摩根以能捕捉潜台词、能读懂字里行间甚至言外之意而自豪。当她做得好时，她能立即听到反馈。当你获得笑声时，那真是一种极大的自尊心提升。这就像即时的认可，而且令人振奋。她在最近的一场演出中就是这种感觉。我做了一件事。我在舞台上像一条鼻涕虫。
I like got on the floor and I like acted like a slug. I inch-wormed across the stage. Her fellow actors lit up. The audience exploded in laughter. When Morgan walked out of the theater that night, she was practically bursting. I just needed to do something with my energy. I didn't want to just go home and go to sleep. Just then, this guy walked out of nowhere. He was carrying a tripod and a bunch of other stuff. Like a sack with stuff in it.
我趴在地板上，像鼻涕虫一样蠕动。我像尺蠖一样爬过舞台。她的演员同伴们兴奋起来。观众爆发出阵阵笑声。那天晚上摩根走出剧院时，几乎要乐开了花。我只是需要发泄一下精力。我不想直接回家睡觉。就在这时，这个家伙不知从哪儿冒了出来。他带着一个三脚架和一堆其他东西。就像一个装满东西的袋子。
And he was just like, does anybody want to buy this tripod? And I was like, yeah, I want to buy this tripod. I think I could get a lot of you set of a tripod. I was like, how much? And he said $25. And also, I'm going And he said, $25. And also, I'm gonna give you this $50 Amazon gift card. And I was like, okay, a tripod and a $50 Amazon gift card for $25. Wow, this guy is so cool.
他问：“有人想买这个三脚架吗？”我说：“是的，我想买这个三脚架。我觉得我能用上它。”我问：“多少钱？”他说：“25美元。而且，我还要给你这张50美元的亚马逊礼品卡。”我当时想，好吧，一个三脚架加一张50美元的亚马逊礼品卡只要25美元。哇，这家伙太酷了。
I'm totally gonna do that. The high she fell from inch warming across the stage, just got even higher. Morgan walked with a guy to an ATM. I got my money in 20s, so I either had to give him $20 or $40. She asked if she could give him $20, rather than the full $25. He was like, you give me whatever you want to give me. And I was like, you're so cool. I'm going to give you $40.
我一定要买。她在舞台上蠕动带来的兴奋感又提升了一个档次。摩根陪那个人走到自动取款机前。我的钱都是20美元面值的，所以我要么给他20美元，要么给他40美元。她问能不能只给他20美元，而不是全额25美元。他说：“你想给多少就给多少。”我说：“你太酷了。我要给你40美元。”
And I gave him $40. And then he gave me like a shoe box full of other random things. And I was like, he's so cool. Morgan felt like she had hit the jackpot. There was a lufa in there. There was a bunch of pens. And I got really excited about the pens, because I don't know, I just love pens. lufa in there. There's a bunch of pens and I got really excited about the pens because I don't know I just love pens like stress balls in there. There was like a diamond cleaner. I've never heard of a diamond cleaner before but it's got like bristles at the end and like this juice on the inside.
我给了他40美元。然后他给了我一个装满各种杂物的鞋盒。我当时想，他真是太酷了。摩根觉得自己中了大奖。里面有一个沐浴球。还有一堆笔。我对那些笔感到非常兴奋，因为我不知道，我就是喜欢笔。里面还有压力球。还有一个钻石清洁器。我以前从没听说过钻石清洁器，但它末端有刷毛，里面还有液体。
What else is in there? I've seen crafts supplies. I've also threw in a pair of women's shoes. They weren't my size but I was like I could sell those. This is awesome. Morgan couldn't wait to show her roommates the loot. She burst into her apartment and told them about her unbelievable good fortune. They were like, what is wrong with you? They were like, okay, what this guy did is he took this stuff out of cars that weren't locked and then he sold it to you for money. And slowly, like, my universe just, like, unraveled. And I was like, no! I just bought a bunch of stolen stuff. Why did Morgan, who prides herself on being able to read
里面还有什么？我看到了工艺品。我还扔进去了一双女鞋。虽然不是我的尺码，但我想我可以把它们卖掉。这太棒了。摩根迫不及待地想向室友展示她的战利品。她冲进公寓，告诉她们自己不可思议的好运。她们说：“你脑子有病吗？”她们说：“好吧，这家伙做的是从没锁的车里偷东西，然后卖给你换钱。”慢慢地，我的世界观崩塌了。我说：“不！我刚买了一堆赃物。”为什么摩根，这个以能读懂
subtext and situations, fail to see what seemed obvious to her friends? I like to think of myself as like a pretty logical person, but in that moment I didn't have any logic. Like I wasn't questioning the situation. I was just being super impulsive, and so in that way I think I was being a pretty different person. It's as if there are two people within Morgan and neither understands the other.
潜台词和局势而自豪的人，却没能看出朋友们一眼就能看出的问题？我喜欢认为自己是一个相当理性的人，但在那一刻，我没有任何逻辑。我没有质疑这种情况。我只是表现得超级冲动，所以我觉得在那一刻，我变成了一个完全不同的人。就好像摩根体内有两个人，谁也不理解谁。
Logical Morgan thinks impulsive Morgan made a glaring mistake, but impulsive Morgan is just as bewildered by logical Morgan. Who would pass up a deal like this? George Lewinstein understands what Morgan was experiencing. George lives in the Pittsburgh area, which is home to some of the steepest hills in America. He used to run those hills every week with his friend, Jules. We would get absolutely exhausted on the way up, and we kind of be egging one another on and be feeling very, very miserable.
理性的摩根认为冲动的摩根犯了一个明显的错误，但冲动的摩根对理性的摩根同样感到困惑。谁会拒绝这样的交易呢？乔治·洛温斯坦理解摩根的经历。乔治住在匹兹堡地区，那里有美国最陡峭的一些山坡。他过去每周都会和朋友朱尔斯一起跑这些山坡。我们在上坡时会精疲力竭，互相打气，感觉非常非常痛苦。
On the way up to the peak, all he could think of was the pain. But moments later, it was all forgotten within maybe 10, 20 seconds. The more George thought about it, the more it seemed like a puzzle. As he was climbing the hill, the idea of relief was inconceivable. The pain felt endless. But the moment he crested the hill, the pain faded so quickly that in his memory, it hadn't been so bad. A few days later, he would lace up his shoes and go running with jewels again. It occurred to George that this gap in perception was psychologically important and applied to more than just the pain of running.
在爬向顶峰的过程中，他脑子里想的只有痛苦。但几分钟后，这一切在10到20秒内就被遗忘了。乔治越想越觉得这像个谜。当他爬坡时，解脱的想法是不可想象的。痛苦感觉永无止境。但当他到达山顶的那一刻，痛苦消退得如此之快，以至于在他的记忆中，那并没有那么糟糕。几天后，他会再次系好鞋带，和朱尔斯一起跑步。乔治意识到这种感知上的差距在心理上很重要，而且不仅适用于跑步的痛苦。
I realized that when you're not in pain or cold or experiencing a powerful emotion like anger or fear, it's very difficult to imagine yourself in that situation. There is a reason this happens. Emotions completely transform us as people, so when we're in one emotional state, as if we're a different person, then we are when we're in a different emotional state. George has thought about this phenomenon a lot. As a professor of psychology and economics at Carnegie Mellon University, he has conducted dozens of studies to understand how our emotional states affect us. One of his
我意识到，当你没有感到痛苦、寒冷或经历愤怒、恐惧等强烈情绪时，很难想象自己处于那种状态。这种情况发生是有原因的。情绪彻底改变了我们作为人的状态，所以当我们处于一种情绪状态时，就好像我们是另一个人，与我们处于另一种情绪状态时完全不同。乔治对这种现象思考了很多。作为卡内基梅隆大学的心理学和经济学教授，他进行了数十项研究，以了解我们的情绪状态如何影响我们。他
earliest studies involved ice water. My colleague wanted to be the guinea pig for the studies, and you're supposed to put your hand in the cold water for like a minute. He put his hand in the cold water, and 20 seconds later he pulled it out. And then a minute later he said, hand on the cold water and 20 seconds later he pulled it out and then a minute later he said, that's ridiculous, I can do it because he couldn't remember the pain anymore. Expecting fully that he would be able to sustain the minute in the cold water and then about 20 seconds later he pulled his hand out again. It was just like what George experienced on his runs. As soon as his colleague pulled his hand out of the freezing water,
最早的研究之一涉及冰水。我的同事想成为研究的实验对象，你需要把手放在冷水里大约一分钟。他把手放进冷水里，20秒后就抽了出来。一分钟后他说：“这太荒谬了，我能做到。”因为他已经记不住那种痛苦了。他满怀信心地认为自己能坚持一分钟，结果大约20秒后他又把手抽了出来。这就像乔治在跑步时的经历。当他的同事把手从冰冷的水中抽出来时，
it was like he was struck with amnesia. George came up with a name for what was happening, the hot cold empathy gap. the Thiccac. Usually, when we think about empathy, we think about how we relate to other people. Georgia's insight is that we regularly lack empathy for ourselves when we are in a different emotional state. When we are angry, we cannot imagine being calm. When we are tranquil, it's hard to imagine being so angry that we could hurt someone. The hot-called empathy gap can also be caused by physiological
就像得了失忆症一样。乔治为这种现象起了一个名字：冷热共情差距（Hot-Cold Empathy Gap）。通常，当我们想到共情时，我们想到的是我们如何与他人产生共鸣。乔治的洞察是，当我们处于不同的情绪状态时，我们经常对自己缺乏共情。当我们愤怒时，我们无法想象自己会冷静。当我们平静时，很难想象自己会愤怒到伤害别人。冷热共情差距也可能由生理
states. When we are really hungry, all our resolutions about healthy eating evaporate. When we are full, it's easy to forget what it felt like to be hungry. We imagine that we will stick to salads the next day. The hot and cold in the hot cold empathy gap are a shorthand. They describe strong emotional and physiological states. When we're in a cold state, we're logical, deliberate. When we're in a hot state, our emotions overtake us. Morgan Smiley was in a hot state when a young man sold her a sack of random stuff. In her excitement, huskcepticism failed to kick in.
状态引起。当我们真的很饿时，我们关于健康饮食的所有决心都会烟消云散。当我们吃饱时，很容易忘记饥饿的感觉。我们想象第二天会坚持吃沙拉。冷热共情差距中的“冷”和“热”是一种速记。它们描述了强烈的情绪和生理状态。当我们处于冷状态时，我们是理性的、深思熟虑的。当我们处于热状态时，情绪会压倒我们。摩根·斯迈利在那个年轻人向她兜售杂物时，正处于热状态。在兴奋中，她的怀疑态度没能发挥作用。
Another familiar hot state? Sexual arousal. Can I talk about that on MPR? Like, I don't know. The answer is yes. So parents of young children, here's your warning. When Irene Pemberton was in middle school, she devoted as much time to sex said, as her classmates may have spent hanging out at the mall. Every Sunday evening for about a year, her parents drove her to a unitarian church for a two-hour session.
另一种熟悉的热状态？性唤起。我能在公共广播电台谈论这个吗？我不知道。答案是肯定的。所以，有年幼孩子的家长们，这是给你们的警告。当艾琳·彭伯顿上初中时，她投入在性教育上的时间，可能和同学们花在商场闲逛的时间一样多。大约一年里，每个周日晚上，她的父母都会开车送她去一所一神论教堂参加两小时的课程。
We learned everything, you know, like they had like the condoms, you know, putting on bananas kind of deal. Irene's family also spoke frankly about sex, like the time in high school when Irene got an IUD and had a conversation about it with her mom. I just remember her saying that I still have to use condoms and, you know, to still be careful. In other words, Irene received an unusually candid, comprehensive sex education. All those hours sitting on church couches and talking to our family made her confident
我们学到了所有东西，你知道，比如他们有那种在香蕉上练习戴避孕套的环节。艾琳的家人也坦率地谈论性，比如高中时艾琳装了宫内节育器，并和她妈妈谈论过这件事。我只记得她说我仍然必须使用避孕套，你知道，仍然要小心。换句话说，艾琳接受了非常坦诚、全面的性教育。所有那些坐在教堂沙发上和家人交谈的时间让她确信，
that she'd made good decisions when it came to sex. I was like, well, obviously, obviously I would use condoms. Like if I didn't know the person very well and like we're not monogamous or anything And I probably was like I would do it every time and she did that is until she met one Special suitor. He's just kind of like a like a greasy guy that like wears like overalls with no underwear and like So I think it was cool. I thought I thought I was pretty charmed by that. Wait, how did you know that he wears overalls with no underwear?
在性方面她会做出正确的决定。我想，好吧，显然，显然我会使用避孕套。如果我不了解那个人，而且我们不是一夫一妻制之类的，我可能会想，我每次都会这样做。她确实是这么想的，直到她遇到了一个特别的追求者。他就是那种油腻腻的家伙，穿着没有内裤的背带裤，所以我当时觉得这很酷。我以为我被那种风格迷住了。等等，你怎么知道他穿背带裤没穿内裤？
Oh yeah, that was later. That's my take on him now. Here's what happened before Irene figured out what was or wasn't beneath his overalls. We hung out, had dinner and stuff, and then go back to his place. I'm not the type of person that is just carrying around condoms all the time. He is the type of person that never used condoms. That was really annoying for me, but I was just like, like, the conversation did not happen until we were already getting intimate.
哦，那是后来才知道的。那是他现在给我的印象。这是在艾琳发现他背带裤下面穿了什么之前发生的事。我们一起出去玩，吃晚饭之类的，然后回到他家。我不是那种随身携带避孕套的人。他是那种从不使用避孕套的人。这让我很烦，但当时的情况是，直到我们已经变得亲密时，那个对话才发生。
This is what all her years of sex at training had prepared her for. I'm like, oh, you don't have condoms, okay. In hindsight, Irene realizes this was exactly the situation that called for condoms. Definitely the type of people that never use condoms are probably the type of people that you should use condoms with, in my opinion, at at least because they don't ever use condoms. But in that moment, a different line of reasoning went through her head. I can either choose to not have intercourse or just not have any sex at all. That was not what I really wanted to do. It didn't sound as fun or like do something
这就是她多年性教育为她做的准备。我说，哦，你没有避孕套，好吧。事后看来，艾琳意识到这正是需要避孕套的情况。在我看来，从不使用避孕套的人绝对是那种你应该使用避孕套的人，至少因为他们从不使用避孕套。但在那一刻，另一种推理出现在她的脑海中。我可以选择不发生性行为，或者根本不发生性关系。那不是我真正想做的。那听起来没那么有趣，或者做点
else sexual that still just like would not be my top choice, or just have unprotected sex. And so I was like, this is going to be okay, just this one time, and it's not a big deal, and it'll be fine. And so then I did that. It's a perfect illustration of an empathy gap. This is psychologist George Lewinstein again. When you listen to her description of what happened, it's a very kind of clinical description
别的性行为，那也不是我的首选，或者就进行无保护性行为。所以我当时想，这会没事的，就这一次，没什么大不了的，会没事的。于是我就那样做了。这是共情差距的一个完美例证。这是心理学家乔治·洛温斯坦再次强调的。当你听她描述发生的事情时，这是一种非常临床的描述，
because when she was talking to you, she wasn't in an aroused state. So she was talking to you as if she was really making a decision when probably in the heat of the moment. She was just very kind of swept up in the course of things. Irene wasn't thinking back to what her mom said about condoms. She also wasn't thinking about what she just learned in class on the history of the AIDS epidemic. Hot State Irene didn't say what cold State Irene would have predicted she would say.
因为当她和你交谈时，她并不处于被唤起的状态。所以她和你交谈时，就好像她真的在做决定，而实际上在那种热血沸腾的时刻，她只是被事态的发展冲昏了头脑。艾琳没有回想她妈妈关于避孕套的话。她也没有想到她在课堂上刚学的关于艾滋病流行历史的知识。热状态下的艾琳没有说出冷状态下的艾琳所预测的话。
No one has to have sex, so I would have just said, okay, another time. I asked Irene if she felt pressured into having sex. I really wanted to do it, so I feel like it was fully my choice. It was a good time. I felt like I was pretty satisfied with the results aside from me feeling like, like, cheese, I shouldn't have done the, you know, unprotected sex part. Once the night was over, it wasn't long before cool-headed Irene reappeared.
没有人必须发生性关系，所以我本会说，好吧，下次吧。我问艾琳她是否感到被迫发生性关系。我真的很想做，所以我感觉这完全是我的选择。那是一段美好的时光。我觉得除了我感觉“天哪，我不应该进行无保护性行为”之外，我对结果还算满意。夜晚结束后，没过多久，冷静的艾琳又出现了。
She was reading for class about the risks of unprotected sex and HIV. So, like, my brain immediately is like, oh my god, I have made a mistake. This is the one time you have unprotected sex. Like, it could be like really bad or something like that. Three days after that first date, she went out again with the same guy. Before the date, I really clearly told herself what would happen and what would not. Going into it, I was like, not tonight, I'm not gonna have, I'm gonna have, I'm gonna have sex tonight and then I go on hang out with him and I'm really distracted.
她正在为课程阅读关于无保护性行为和艾滋病毒风险的内容。所以，我的大脑立刻反应过来，天哪，我犯了一个错误。这是你唯一一次进行无保护性行为。这可能会非常糟糕之类的。第一次约会三天后，她又和同一个人出去了。约会前，我非常清楚地告诉自己会发生什么，不会发生什么。去之前，我心想，今晚不行，我不会，我不会在今晚发生性关系。然后我去和他见面，我真的很分心。
The problem was cold state Irene had not anticipated how hot state Irene would act again. I still did not bring condoms and I made the same choice. Although that time I was like, well, you know, that was like three days ago, and nothing bad has happened yet from that. So maybe you just one more time. Just like Morgan Smollie kind understand, why she trusted a guy selling random things on the street,
问题是，冷状态下的艾琳没有预料到热状态下的艾琳会再次做出同样的举动。我还是没带避孕套，我做了同样的选择。虽然那次我想，好吧，你知道，那是三天前的事了，到现在还没发生什么坏事。所以也许就再来一次。就像摩根·斯迈利无法理解为什么她会信任一个在街上兜售杂物的家伙一样，
Irene doesn't recognize the person who made these impulsive decisions. I was telling my friend about this and I'm like, I don't know that girl. Like I don't know her. George Lonestein is sympathetic to Irene. Sexual arousal can lead people to do things they would never expect. Downplay risks, rationalized behavior, and come up with excuses. Things that make people wake up the next day and go, oh no, what did I do?
艾琳也不认识那个做出这些冲动决定的人。我告诉我的朋友这件事时，我说，我不认识那个女孩。我不认识她。乔治·洛温斯坦对艾琳表示同情。性唤起会导致人们做出他们从未预料到的事情。淡化风险、合理化行为、找借口。这些事情让人们在第二天醒来时说，哦不，我做了什么？
Beyond having unprotected sex with a date, sexual arousal can also drive more troubling behavior. Years ago, George ran experiments where men were given different scenarios to imagine. In one study, they went on a date with a woman named Susan, and things were going well on the date. At some point, they're kind of on the verge of getting into more serious physical things, and Susan says she wants to stop. And we ask people, what would you do in this situation?
除了与约会对象进行无保护性行为外，性唤起还会导致更令人不安的行为。多年前，乔治做过实验，让男性想象不同的场景。在一项研究中，他们与一个名叫苏珊的女性约会，约会进行得很顺利。在某个时刻，他们即将发生更严重的身体接触，苏珊说她想停下来。我们问人们，在这种情况下你会怎么做？
The studies put some men into a state of sexual arousal. In one experiment, the men were shown pictures of nude women. In all the studies, a control group featured men who were not sexually aroused. George found that sexually aroused men were more likely to say they would encourage a woman to drink to increase her willingness to have sex. They were more likely to say they would encourage a woman to drink to increase her willingness to have sex. They were more likely to say they would be willing to slip a drug into her drink. They also said that if she resisted them, they would be less likely to take no for an answer. Did men realize how their behavior changed as a result of the intervention? In one experiment, George had men get sexually aroused, but then brought them back to the lab the following day. These men had
这些研究让一些男性处于性唤起状态。在一个实验中，男性被展示了裸女的照片。在所有的研究中，对照组的男性没有受到性唤起。乔治发现，受到性唤起的男性更有可能说他们会鼓励女性喝酒以增加她发生性关系的意愿。他们更有可能说他们会鼓励女性喝酒以增加她发生性关系的意愿。他们更有可能说他们愿意在她的饮料里下药。他们还说，如果她拒绝他们，他们不太可能接受“不”这个答案。男性是否意识到他们的行为因干预而改变了？在一个实验中，乔治让男性受到性唤起，但随后在第二天把他们带回实验室。这些男性有
time to cool down. We actually got a surprising result in that condition. The surprising result was that the men in this condition didn't just say they would respect the woman's boundaries. They indicated they would be even more mindful of consent than the men who had not been aroused. George doesn't know exactly why they got this result, but he has a guess. They can't remember that how aroused they were, so they think, oh, you know, I saw these scantily clad women and I wasn't very aroused, so probably I'd behave really well on the date. George and other researchers have repeatedly found that people are worse at predicting their behavior
时间冷静下来。我们在那种情况下实际上得到了一个令人惊讶的结果。令人惊讶的结果是，在这种条件下的男性不仅说他们会尊重女性的界限。他们表示，他们会比那些没有被唤起的男性更加注意同意。乔治不知道他们为什么会得到这个结果，但他有一个猜测。他们记不住自己当时有多么兴奋，所以他们想，哦，你知道，我看到了这些衣着暴露的女性，但我并没有很兴奋，所以可能我在约会时会表现得很好。乔治和其他研究人员反复发现，人们在预测自己的行为方面表现得很差，
in a hot state. After, they will already experience that hot state. These findings show the hot-called empathy gap works in two directions across time. First, we're not great at predicting how we'll behave in a different emotional state. That's the prospect prospective empathy gap. But we also have trouble understanding our actions in the past.
特别是在热状态下。事后，他们已经体验过那种热状态。这些发现表明，冷热共情差距在时间上是双向起作用的。首先，我们不擅长预测自己在不同情绪状态下会如何表现。这就是前瞻性共情差距。但我们也难以理解我们过去的行动。
Our memories are faulty, especially when it comes to how intense feelings can overwhelm us. Think about George's colleague who couldn't remember how painful it felt, just one minute earlier, to have his hands submerged in icy water. So that's a retrospective empathy gap. Irene's story shows both these gaps. Before she was aroused, Irene was certain she would apply everything she had been taught by church leaders about unsafe sex. But soon after her date with the overalls guy, Cole stayed Irene could no longer put herself back into the shoes of
我们的记忆是有缺陷的，尤其是当强烈的感受压倒我们时。想想乔治的那位同事，他甚至记不住一分钟前把手浸在冰水里有多痛苦。这就是回顾性共情差距。艾琳的故事展示了这两种差距。在被唤起之前，艾琳确信她会应用教堂领袖教给她的关于不安全性的所有知识。但在与那个穿背带裤的家伙约会后不久，冷状态下的艾琳再也无法回到
Hot State Irene. I don't know that girl. This incomprehension led her to feel confident about how she would behave on her next day. She forgot that Hot State Irene would not be able to access her Cold State logic. This is true not just for sexual arousal. It's true for hunger, pain, addiction, depression. If you are not depressed and your friend tells you, oh I feel really depressed, you might say, oh that's really terrible, I feel really sorry for you, but if you're not depressed yourself, it's
热状态下艾琳的处境中去了。我不认识那个女孩。这种无法理解导致她对自己在下一次约会中的表现感到自信。她忘记了热状态下的艾琳将无法获取她冷状态下的逻辑。这不仅适用于性唤起。它也适用于饥饿、疼痛、成瘾、抑郁。如果你没有抑郁，而你的朋友告诉你，哦，我感到非常抑郁，你可能会说，哦，那太糟糕了，我真的很同情你，但如果你自己没有抑郁，
really very very difficult to imagine what they're going through. This gets at one of the most troubling consequences of the hot cold empathy gap. Not only does it keep us from understanding ourselves, it can keep us from understanding other people. I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. A reminder, this episode contains stories about sex, sex work, and sexual harassment. Feelings like hunger, thirst, and anger can cause us to act impulsively. When we are in these hot states, we can say and do and think things that we never imagined possible even minutes earlier.
真的非常非常难想象他们正在经历什么。这触及了冷热共情差距最令人不安的后果之一。它不仅使我们无法理解自己，还可能使我们无法理解他人。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。提醒一下，本集包含有关性、性工作和性骚扰的故事。饥饿、口渴和愤怒等感觉会导致我们冲动行事。当我们处于这些热状态时，我们可能会说出、做出和想到几分钟前从未想象过的事情。
But sometimes hot states don't get us fired up. They paralyze us. This can be true for emotions like embarrassment or shame or fear. Nina Fuller learned this decades ago. She was in her early 20s studying art at George Washington University. But she and her husband needed part-time jobs to pay for school. She found a listing for a job in the classified section of the newspaper. And I saw this, a head that said, be a masseuse, no experience necessary. It was a way to earn money, and she'd get trained on the job. Nina called the number.
但有时热状态并不会让我们兴奋。它们会让我们瘫痪。对于尴尬、羞耻或恐惧等情绪，情况可能确实如此。尼娜·富勒几十年前就学到了这一点。她20出头，在乔治华盛顿大学学习艺术。但她和丈夫需要兼职工作来支付学费。她在报纸的分类广告栏里看到了一个工作列表。我看到了这个标题，写着：做按摩师，无需经验。这是一种赚钱的方式，而且可以在工作中接受培训。尼娜拨打了那个号码。
She was given a date and time to show up. I put my hair in the little braids and drove myself to this place and walked in. The space Nina entered looked like the waiting room of a dentist's office. Nina checked in. And somebody told me to take my hair out of the braids. I'm like, why would I do that? You know, and they were like, well, I remember they said, you know, these guys that come here, they're going home to their wives and they have high stressful jobs and they want to relax before they go home. Oh, my God. All right, you know.
她被告知了出现的日期和时间。我把头发扎成小辫子，开车去了那个地方，走了进去。尼娜进入的空间看起来像牙医诊所的候诊室。尼娜办理了登记。有人告诉我把头发上的辫子拆掉。我说，我为什么要那样做？你知道，他们说，嗯，我记得他们说，你知道，这些来这里的家伙，他们要回家见妻子，他们工作压力很大，想在回家前放松一下。天哪。好吧，你知道。
They were other women in the room. They looked about the same age as her. The women were asked to line up, side by side. Behind them, there were doors to massage rooms. I figured okay, the guys come in, they pick the women and go into the room and get a massage. A man wearing a suit came in and chose Nina. She walked into one of the rooms with him. He took his clothes off. Then I gave him a massage.
房间里还有其他女性。她们看起来和她年纪差不多。这些女性被要求并排站好。在她们身后，是按摩室的门。我想，好吧，男人们进来，挑选女性，然后进房间接受按摩。一个穿着西装的男人走进来，选中了尼娜。她和他一起走进其中一个房间。他脱掉了衣服。然后我给他做了按摩。
I mean, how do I even know how to do that. I don't know. I just figured what made it up as I went along. That on the job training she expected to get never happened. And then he rolled over. And I'm alone in this room with this guy. And he rolled over and he had an erection. And I was just what? I mean, it wasn't until that point that I thought, oh, what have I gotten myself into? You know, like, what the hell?
我的意思是，我甚至怎么知道该怎么做？我不知道。我只是边做边编。她预期的在职培训从未发生。然后他翻过身来。我独自在这个房间里和这个家伙在一起。他翻过身，勃起了。我当时只是“什么？”我的意思是，直到那一刻我才想到，哦，我把自己卷进了什么事情里？你知道，这到底是怎么回事？
Nina says the man made it clear to her that he expected more than a massage. You know, like, what? The hell? Nina says the man made it clear to her that he expected more than a massage. He must have said this is why I'm here. This is what you do. I mean, I think I was probably thinking, how could I not have known that? How? What? You know, what?
尼娜说，那个男人向她明确表示，他期望的不仅仅是按摩。你知道，这到底是怎么回事？尼娜说，那个男人向她明确表示，他期望的不仅仅是按摩。他一定说过这就是我来这里的原因。这就是你要做的。我的意思是，我想我当时可能在想，我怎么可能不知道这一点？怎么会？什么？你知道，什么？
Oh. Oh. The man told Nina, he expected an intimate massage. What? You know, what? Oh. The man told Nina he expected an intimate massage. She gave in. This is the thing that I've wondered for all these years. Like if there was an essay question or there was a multiple choice question and it was like, okay, this happened and these are the choices. You stay and you do what that man wants. You say no, I'm not doing that, what are you nuts? You leave, you get, get walk out,
哦。哦。那个男人告诉尼娜，他期望得到一次亲密的按摩。什么？你知道，什么？哦。那个男人告诉尼娜，他期望得到一次亲密的按摩。她屈服了。这是我多年来一直想知道的事情。就像如果有一道论文题或选择题，内容是：好吧，发生了这种情况，这些是选项。你留下来做那个男人想要的事。你说不，我不做那个，你疯了吗？你离开，你走出去，
get in your car and drive home. I would have probably have checked, I'd walk out and I get in my car and I drive home. And definitely, but that's not what I did. Nina says she doesn't remember whether she gave any more massages that day. The rest of that evening is a blank. But the one thing she does remember
上车开车回家。我可能本会检查一下，我会走出去，上车开车回家。绝对会，但那不是我做的。尼娜说她不记得那天她是否还做了其他按摩。那天晚上的其余时间是一片空白。但她确实记得的一件事
is that she stayed for the whole shift. I asked her why she felt compelled to stay. When she herself would have predicted, she would do otherwise. I think I was just embarrassed to think that I had didn't know what was going on. And sort of getting your bag and walking out would have meant what, would have said what. That I had put myself in a situation that I didn't, that I had no idea what was going on when I got there. And that would mean what?
是她坚持到了整个轮班结束。我问她为什么觉得必须留下来。当她自己本会预测她会做相反的事情时。我想我只是因为想到自己不知道发生了什么而感到尴尬。那种收拾包走人意味着什么，会说明什么？说明我把自己置于一个我完全不知道发生了什么的境地。那意味着什么？
Maybe that would mean that I was stupid. You know, maybe I didn't want to appear as naive and domazai felt at that moment. Like everyone else that was there knew what they were doing that why they were there. Yeah, maybe I didn't want to. I don't know. Maybe I didn't want to be a peer-stupid. I think that's a very common response that people say,
也许那意味着我很蠢。你知道，也许我不想表现得像那一刻我感觉到的那么天真和无知。就像那里所有其他人都知道他们在做什么，为什么他们在那里。是的，也许我不想。我不知道。也许我不想显得很蠢。我认为这是一个非常普遍的反应，人们说，
yeah, I went through with it because, clearly, I should ask more on the front end, and I didn't, and I didn't want to look like I didn't know what I was doing, so you just go through with it. This is psychologist Julie Woodzica. I am a professor at Washington and Lee University. Julie has spent years studying how people react in situations like the one Nina found herself in.
是的，我坚持下去了，因为显然，我应该在前期多问问，但我没有，我不想看起来像个什么都不懂的人，所以你就坚持下去了。这是心理学家朱莉·伍兹卡。我是华盛顿与李大学的教授。朱莉花了很多年研究人们在尼娜所处的那种情况下会有什么反应。
Many of these people ask themselves the same questions. Why didn't I speak up? Why didn't I protest? Why did I go through with it?" Some of Julie's earliest thoughts on sexual harassment and abuse came together when she was a college student. Like millions of others, she witnessed the tectonic event in 1991 that brought the term sexual harassment into popular use. It was a Senate testimony of law professor Anita Hill. use. It was a Senate testimony of law professor Anita Hill. She claimed Supreme Court nominee Clarence Thomas had sexually harassed her while he was her supervisor. After a brief discussion of work, he would turn the conversation to a discussion of sexual
许多这些人问自己同样的问题。“我为什么没开口？我为什么没抗议？我为什么坚持下去了？”朱莉对性骚扰和虐待的一些最早想法是在她还是大学生时形成的。像数以百万计的其他人一样，她见证了1991年那个将“性骚扰”一词引入大众使用的重大事件。那是法学教授安妮塔·希尔的参议院证词。她声称最高法院提名人克拉伦斯·托马斯在她担任主管时对她进行了性骚扰。在简短的工作讨论后，他会把谈话转向性
matters. Before an all-male Judiciary Committee, she alleged he had made sexual advances and told explicit jokes. He commented on what I was wearing in terms of whether it made me more or less sexually attractive. He talked about pornographic materials. On several occasions, Thomas told me graphically of his own sexual prowess. The nation was wrapped and divided. I remember really, really vividly people saying like, no, she's lying. She's got to be lying.
话题。在全男性的司法委员会面前，她指控他曾进行性挑逗并讲露骨的笑话。他评论我的穿着，说这是否让我看起来更有或更少的性吸引力。他谈论色情材料。在几次场合中，托马斯生动地向我讲述了他自己的性能力。全国都陷入了震惊和分裂。我非常非常生动地记得人们说，不，她在撒谎。她一定在撒谎。
There was one specific detail that led many people to that conclusion. After Anita Hill allegedly experienced harassment, she was given an opportunity to work for Clarence Thomas again. She took it. During the hearings, Senator Allen Simpson pressed her on this point. If what you say this man said to you, occurred, why and God's name when he left his position of power or status or authority over you and you left it.
有一个具体的细节导致许多人得出那个结论。在安妮塔·希尔据称遭受骚扰后，她获得了再次为克拉伦斯·托马斯工作的机会。她接受了。在听证会上，参议员艾伦·辛普森就这一点向她施压。如果这个男人对你所说的话确实发生了，为什么，看在上帝的份上，当他离开对你拥有权力、地位或权威的职位，而你也离开时。
In 1983, why in God's name would you ever speak to a man like that the rest of your life? That's a very good question. And I'm sure that I can't not answer that to your satisfaction. That is one of the things that I have tried to do today. I have suggested that I was afraid of retaliation. I was afraid of damage to my professional life.
在1983年，为什么看在上帝的份上，你还会和那样的人说话？这是一个非常好的问题。我相信我无法让你满意地回答这个问题。这是我今天试图做的事情之一。我暗示过我害怕报复。我害怕我的职业生涯受到损害。
And I believe you that you have to understand that this response, and that's one of the things that I have come to understand about harassment, that this response, this kind of I have come to understand about harassment. This response, this kind of response, is not atypical. And I can't explain. It takes an expert in psychology to explain how that can happen. But it can happen, because it happened to me.
我相信你，你必须明白这种反应，这也是我开始了解骚扰的事情之一，这种反应，这种……我开始了解骚扰。这种反应，这种反应，并非不典型。我无法解释。这需要心理学专家来解释它是如何发生的。但它确实会发生，因为它发生在我身上。
By the early 2000s, Julie had become one of those experts in psychology. She and her collaborator, Marianne Lafrance, found themselves talking about how people reacted to Anita Hill's testimony. We noticed a lot of people said I'd never would have responded that way if I had been sexually harassed, I would have, like I would have told them to stop, and I probably would have left the job, I definitely would to follow him to another job. Julie realized some of the most important questions about sexual harassment had not been studied at all.
到21世纪初，朱莉已经成为那些心理学专家之一。她和她的合作者玛丽安·拉弗朗斯发现自己在讨论人们对安妮塔·希尔证词的反应。我们注意到很多人说，如果我受到性骚扰，我绝不会那样反应，我会，比如我会告诉他们停止，我可能会离开那份工作，我绝对会，绝不会跟随他去另一份工作。朱莉意识到关于性骚扰的一些最重要的问题根本没有被研究过。
There was a lot on how women remembered responding and there was a good amount on how they anticipated they would respond, but there was nothing at that point on looking at how women actually responded. Julie set out to understand how women react to sexual harassment as it's happening. In the first phase of the study, we had roughly 200 women come into the lab and we gave them a scenario that they needed to read through. Here's the scenario. You're interviewing for a job as a research assistant.
关于女性如何记得自己的反应有很多研究，关于她们预期自己会如何反应也有不少研究，但在当时，对于女性实际上是如何反应的，却没有任何研究。朱莉着手了解女性在性骚扰发生时是如何反应的。在研究的第一阶段，我们让大约200名女性来到实验室，给她们一个需要阅读的场景。这是场景。你正在面试一份研究助理的工作。
The interviewer is in his mid-30s. You're in an office alone with him and you know after initial greeting he starts asking you some questions. This time the interview questions. Until this one. Do you have a boyfriend? A few questions later. Do people find you desirable? The interview continues. Then he asks, do you think it's important for women to wear bras to work? Remember, this is a job interview. The women who participated in Julie's study imagined the situation
面试官30多岁。你和他单独在一个办公室里，你知道在最初的问候后，他开始问你一些问题。这次是面试问题。直到这一问。“你有男朋友吗？”几个问题后。“人们觉得你有吸引力吗？”面试继续。然后他问，“你认为女性在工作中穿胸罩重要吗？”记住，这是一次工作面试。参与朱莉研究的女性想象了这个情况，
and were asked to describe how they thought they'd react. The response was overwhelming. About 90% of the women thought that they would respond in a very assertive and sometimes aggressive way. So about 60% said that they would confront assertively, that they would say to him, that's inappropriate. You shouldn't ask those questions.
并被要求描述她们认为自己会如何反应。反应是压倒性的。大约90%的女性认为她们会以一种非常坚定，有时甚至是激进的方式做出反应。所以大约60%的人说她们会坚定地对抗，她们会对他讲，那是不恰当的。你不应该问这些问题。
About 30% said that they would leave the interview or that they would often say, I'd tell them off or it's slap them and then leave. Besides confronting the interviewer and leaving the interview, many participants said they do something else. 68% of all respondents said that they would refuse to answer at least one of those three questions. The women were not only asked to predict what they do, but to describe the emotion, they would feel.
大约30%的人说她们会离开面试，或者她们经常说，我会斥责他或者扇他一巴掌然后离开。除了对抗面试官并离开面试外，许多参与者说她们会做别的事情。68%的受访者表示，她们会拒绝回答那三个问题中的至少一个。这些女性不仅被要求预测她们会做什么，还要描述她们会感受到的情绪。
A lot of women about 30% said that they would feel anger. Women who predicted they'd be angry were more likely to say they'd confront the interviewer. Anger was galvanizing. We're interested in fear too, how many people thought they'd be a little bit afraid, and only 2% of people said that they would be afraid. And fear was not correlated with confronting. So this doesn't sound like Nina Fouler at all. These women were all assertive, angry, indignant.
很多女性，大约30%的人说她们会感到愤怒。预测自己会愤怒的女性更有可能说她们会对抗面试官。愤怒是具有激励作用的。我们也对恐惧感兴趣，有多少人认为她们会有一点害怕，只有2%的人说她们会感到害怕。而且恐惧与对抗并不相关。所以这听起来一点也不像尼娜·富勒。这些女性都很坚定、愤怒、愤慨。
They were sure they would tell the man off. In the second part of the study, Julie set up an experiment to test whether women actually did what they forecast they would do. We had 50 women who were applying for a job. The job was a research assistant in a lab. The women would come into the interview and we had covert cameras set up. Their interviewer was a man in his mid-30s. He asked those three questions.
她们确信自己会斥责那个男人。在研究的第二部分，朱莉设计了一个实验来测试女性是否真的做了她们预测会做的事情。我们有50名正在申请工作的女性。这份工作是实验室的研究助理。女性会来参加面试，我们设置了隐蔽摄像头。她们的面试官是一个30多岁的男人。他问了那三个问题。
The same three questions from the first phase of the study. Do you have a boyfriend? Do people find you desirable? Do you think it's important for women to wear bras to work? What was different here was that the women weren't imagining a job interview. They were in a job interview, or so they believed. So how did they react? Did 90% respond assertively? Tell the interviewer off?
与研究第一阶段相同的三个问题。你有男朋友吗？人们觉得你有吸引力吗？你认为女性在工作中穿胸罩重要吗？这里不同的是，女性不是在想象工作面试。她们是在进行工作面试，或者她们认为是这样。那么她们是如何反应的？90%的人坚定地回应了吗？斥责面试官了吗？
Slap him and walk out. Nobody left. Every single person answered every single question. Some women did speak up, but generally not until the end of the interview. Thirty-six percent of the participants at that point said very politely, yeah, I was just wondering, you know, why did you ask about me being desirable? There was another important difference between the women's responses in the two parts of the study.
扇他一巴掌然后走人？没有人离开。每个人都回答了每一个问题。一些女性确实开口了，但通常直到面试结束时才开口。36%的参与者在那个时候非常有礼貌地说，是的，我只是想知道，你知道，你为什么要问我是否有吸引力？女性在研究两部分中的反应还有另一个重要的区别。
So you remember in the anticipated study, most women responded that they'd be angry, very few, fearful, and it was the flip in this study. So we found that many women reported feeling afraid in that situation and anger was not very much reported. While the women who imagined being sexually harassed thought they'd be angry and that anger would propel them to act, women who were faced to face with a harasser, in fact experienced fear.
还记得在预期的研究中吗？大多数女性回答说她们会感到愤怒，很少有人感到恐惧，但这项研究的结果却截然相反。我们发现，许多女性在那种情况下报告说感到害怕，而愤怒则很少被提及。虽然那些想象自己受到性骚扰的女性认为自己会感到愤怒，并且这种愤怒会促使她们采取行动，但实际上，当女性面对骚扰者时，她们经历的是恐惧。
There's clearly an aspect of the study that should make you uneasy. Researchers brought in unsuspecting women for what they thought were job interviews, and then subjected them to harassment to see how they would behave. Julie went through rigorous ethical clearance to conduct the study. After it was over, she debriefed the volunteers and gave them the option of pulling their data. What explains the enormous gap between what women think they do and what they actually do?
显然，这项研究中有一个方面会让你感到不安。研究人员让毫无戒心的女性参与她们以为是求职面试的活动，然后对她们进行骚扰，以观察她们的行为。朱莉在进行这项研究时通过了严格的伦理审查。结束后，她对志愿者进行了访谈，并让她们选择是否撤回自己的数据。是什么解释了女性认为自己会怎么做与她们实际会怎么做之间巨大的差距呢？
When we're asked to anticipate how we would respond, we don't take into account one how our emotional state in that moment, especially if it's a highly charged moment, will impact our behavior. We're not thinking about how being in a hot state might affect us. We also don't understand very well, I think, the strength of the situation and just what would be the cost of leaving, how would people receive us? They're not thinking about how they're going to be feeling, they're not thinking about even really the other people in the situation, they're just thinking about what
当我们被要求预判自己会如何反应时，我们没有考虑到一点：我们在那一刻的情绪状态，尤其是在高度紧张的时刻，会如何影响我们的行为。我们没有考虑到处于“热状态”下可能会如何影响我们。我认为，我们对情境的力量以及离开的代价——人们会如何看待我们——理解得也不够透彻。她们没有考虑自己会有什么感觉，甚至没有真正考虑情境中的其他人，她们只是在想
would they do? It's like wanting to build a house and showing up to the ground breaking with only a sketch, a sketch that doesn't take into consideration any of the context or any of the obstacles, like the engineering requirements or the zoning laws or the funding. If you had outlined the scenario that Nina Fuller found herself in, she would have told you ahead of time that she would have walked out of the massage parlour. What she would not have been able to factor into her thinking was the change in her emotional state, her surprise,
她们会怎么做？这就像想要盖一栋房子，却只带着一张草图出现在奠基仪式上，这张草图没有考虑到任何背景或障碍，比如工程要求、分区法律或资金问题。如果你预先勾勒出尼娜·富勒所处的场景，她会提前告诉你，她会走出按摩院。她无法纳入考量的是她情绪状态的变化、她的惊讶、
her fear, her shock, and how those emotions might have affected her ability to act. You know, if you were to think about that, you would say, oh, I'd be so mad. I'd be so mad at that guy. Like, what's he thinking? But in actuality, she's alone in a room with a guy. She doesn't really know like what this whole situation is except that she's been hired to give a massage and she has no experience doing that.
她的恐惧、她的震惊，以及这些情绪可能如何影响了她的行动能力。你知道，如果你去想这件事，你会说，哦，我会很生气。我会对那个家伙很生气。就像，他在想什么？但实际上，她独自一人和一个男人在一个房间里。她并不真正知道整个情况是什么，只知道她被雇来做按摩，而她对此毫无经验。
And she's probably feeling afraid. She's not feeling angry. One thing to confront someone turns out to be just one step in actually confronting someone, and it is not even the first step. First you have to interpret that something happened, that actually is sexual harassment. Then you have to interpret the event as confrontation worthy. So is this event worthy of confrontation? Or is it really not that big of a deal?
而且她可能感到害怕。她并没有感到愤怒。事实证明，与某人对峙只是实际对峙过程中的一步，甚至还不是第一步。首先，你必须解读出发生了某事，而且那确实是性骚扰。然后，你必须将该事件解读为值得对峙的。那么，这个事件值得对峙吗？还是说这其实没什么大不了的？
Then you have to actually take responsibility to confront. Then you have to decide, or you have to come up with different response options. What am I actually going to do? And then you actually have to do it. So when most people think about confrontation, they think about it being just one step. You know, I'm either going to confront or I'm not going to confront. I'm going to ask it, you know, someone to make it stop or I won't. But in actuality, it's five pretty separate big steps that you have to take to be able to confront at the end. Listening to George Lowenthal and Julie Woodzica made me think about sexual harassment prevention programs.
然后你必须真正承担起对峙的责任。接着你必须决定，或者你必须想出不同的应对方案。我到底要做什么？然后你必须真正去执行。所以，当大多数人想到对峙时，他们认为这只是一步。你知道，我要么去对峙，要么不去。我要么要求某人停止，要么不要求。但实际上，这是五个相当独立的大步骤，你必须完成这些步骤才能最终实现对峙。听了乔治·洛温斯坦和朱莉·伍兹卡的话，我开始思考性骚扰预防项目。
Many of these programs try to address the abuse of power that drives so much sexual harassment. But many also ignore the hot cold empathy gap. The advice given to participants is, respect other people's boundaries. Don't say and do things, you would later regret. People listening might think, sure, that's easy. They're in a cold state and they can't imagine how sexual or
许多这类项目试图解决导致大量性骚扰的权力滥用问题。但许多项目也忽视了“热-冷共情差距”。给参与者的建议是：尊重他人的界限。不要说和做那些你以后会后悔的事情。听众可能会想，当然，这很容易。他们处于“冷状态”，无法想象性或
out-zole can turn them into the kind of people who violate boundaries or make colleagues uneasy. The training programs also tell potential victims and bystanders, don't be silent, report problems. If you see something, say something. People listening think, of course I would never be silent in a situation like that. They go back to their desks with the feeling that they know exactly how they would act in these situations. The hot cold empathy gap doesn't just make us draw the wrong conclusions about our actions and motivations. It can make us unfairly judge mental to what others.
冲动如何能把他们变成那种侵犯界限或让同事感到不安的人。培训项目还告诉潜在的受害者和旁观者：不要沉默，要报告问题。如果你看到了什么，就说出来。听众会想，当然，在这种情况下我绝不会保持沉默。他们带着一种感觉回到办公桌前，认为自己确切地知道在这些情况下会如何行动。热-冷共情差距不仅让我们对自己的行为和动机得出错误的结论，还会让我们不公平地评判他人。
We hear what someone else did, someone like Anita Hill, and think, I would never have done that. I would have acted differently. It's very difficult to make sense of other people's behavior, people who are acting under the influence of emotions that you're not experiencing. George Lowenstein says, our unrealistic sense of how we would act is at the root of our failure to understand others. When we assess whether another person's actions are reasonable, we first imagine how we would behave in that situation. The problem is our perceptions are out of whack with reality. We think we'd be able to control
我们听到别人做了什么，比如安妮塔·希尔，然后想，我绝不会那样做。我会采取不同的行动。要理解他人的行为非常困难，尤其是那些在你不曾经历的情绪影响下行事的人。乔治·洛温斯坦说，我们对自己会如何行动的不切实际的认知，是我们无法理解他人的根源。当我们评估他人的行为是否合理时，我们首先想象自己在那种情况下会如何表现。问题在于，我们的感知与现实脱节了。我们认为自己能够控制
an addiction or slog through pain or confront a harasser. When we come back, we may never be able to avoid the hot cold empathy gap, but there are ways to compensate for it. I was like, I don't know if this is worth it. You know, my legs hurt, my body hurts, I just want to go home and go to sleep right now. I'm Shankar Vedantam and you are listening to Hidden Brain. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. All of us see and do things we would never anticipate saying and doing.
某种瘾，或者忍受痛苦，或者对抗骚扰者。回来后，我们可能永远无法避免热-冷共情差距，但有一些方法可以弥补它。我当时想，我不知道这是否值得。你知道，我的腿很痛，我的身体很痛，我现在只想回家睡觉。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们所有人都会看到并做出一些我们从未预料到会说出或做出的事情。
When we are in the trough of intense emotions, we are impulsive when we should be cautious. We freeze when we think we will be brave. When we look back on our behavior, we are often baffled because we have forgotten how we felt in the heat of the moment. Psychologist George Lowenstein calls this an empathy gap. We often can relate to the other person we become in a different emotional state. We might think that one way to bridge this gap is to see how we behave when we are in the grip of an intense emotion. Surely, after we see how we act in one of these emotional states, we won't be as naive the next time around. We think experience functions like a powerful vaccine once inoculated forever protected. All my research suggests that experiencing something yourself does not provide any
当我们处于强烈情绪的低谷时，我们本该谨慎却变得冲动。我们本以为自己会勇敢，却僵住了。当我们回顾自己的行为时，我们常常感到困惑，因为我们忘记了在那种热血沸腾的时刻我们的感受。心理学家乔治·洛温斯坦称之为“共情差距”。我们往往无法与处于不同情绪状态下的那个自己产生共鸣。我们可能认为弥合这种差距的一种方法是观察我们在处于强烈情绪时是如何表现的。当然，在我们看到自己在这些情绪状态下如何行事后，下次就不会那么天真了。我们认为经验就像一种强效疫苗，一旦接种，就永远受到保护。但我所有的研究都表明，亲身经历并不能提供任何
inoculation against the empathy gap. If experience was a simple fix, Georgia's colleague wouldn't have believed he'd be able to keep his hand in ice water the second time around. Irene would not have had unprotected sex with a no underwear no condoms guy, twice. Most of us don't even get to the point where we recognize how different our hot and cold cells are, but even if we did, that would not be enough to change our behavior. We have to develop the muscle memory to override our instincts in those states. George has found an effective way to do so.
针对共情差距的免疫力。如果经验是一个简单的解决方法，乔治的同事就不会相信他第二次还能把手放在冰水里。艾琳也不会两次与一个不穿内裤、不戴避孕套的男人发生无保护性行为。我们大多数人甚至没有意识到我们的“热自我”和“冷自我”有多么不同，但即使我们意识到了，也不足以改变我们的行为。我们必须培养肌肉记忆，以便在那些状态下覆盖我们的本能。乔治发现了一种有效的方法。
Training. Well, I think what training often does is it diminishes the hot state. So, for example, when I started out in public speaking, I found it very, very painful, anxiety-making. I would get dry mouth, things like that. And then, the more I did it, the less miserable I found it. I still find radio interviews totally miserable. Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
培训。嗯，我认为培训通常所做的是削弱“热状态”。例如，当我刚开始公开演讲时，我发现这非常非常痛苦，令人焦虑。我会口干舌燥，诸如此类。然后，我做得越多，就觉得越不痛苦。我仍然觉得电台采访非常痛苦。哈哈哈哈哈哈。
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha. There's an entire American institution devoted to bridging the hot cold empathy gap in situations far more physically taxing than a radio interview. It's the Army. Military leaders have long understood that there is a way to get soldiers to perform well in battle.
哈哈哈哈哈哈。整个美国有一个机构致力于在比电台采访更具身体挑战性的情况下弥合热-冷共情差距。那就是军队。军事领导人早就明白，有一种方法可以让士兵在战斗中表现出色。
Put them in hot states and teach them, through repetition, to stifle their natural impulses. My name is Anastasia Fish. I'm a second lieutenant in the United States Army and I'm an armor officer. On a February morning in 2019, Anastasia had her roommate drive her to Camp Darby in Georgia. As they approached the camp, they passed a black and yellow sign that Anastasia had seen her friends pose in front off in their Instagram photos.
让他们进入“热状态”，并通过重复训练教他们抑制自己的自然冲动。我叫阿纳斯塔西娅·菲什。我是美国陆军的一名少尉，也是一名装甲军官。2019年2月的一个早晨，阿纳斯塔西娅让她的室友开车送她去佐治亚州的达比营。当他们接近营地时，他们经过了一个黑黄相间的标志，阿纳斯塔西娅曾在她朋友的Instagram照片中看到过她们在前面摆姿势。
The sign read, not for the week or faint-hearted. It's a warning and a boast for Army Ranger School. The school puts recruits through a grueling training program. Graduates often go on to elite units and important assignments. On the first full day of training, Anastasia says she had to take a test. You have two minutes to do 49 push-ups. You have two minutes to do 59 sit-ups. You have 40 minutes to run five miles, and then you have to do six pull-ups right afterwards. In the weeks that followed, Anastasia had to drop
标志上写着：不适合虚弱或胆小的人。这是对陆军游骑兵学校的警告和夸耀。该学校让新兵经历严酷的训练计划。毕业生通常会进入精英部队和重要岗位。在训练的第一整天，阿纳斯塔西娅说她必须参加测试。你有两分钟做49个俯卧撑。你有两分钟做59个仰卧起坐。你有40分钟跑五英里，然后紧接着要做6个引体向上。在接下来的几周里，阿纳斯塔西娅不得不从
from a rope into cold water and swim, wearing her full uniform. She was kept awake for hours on end. She recalls a stretch of nine days where she only got 10 hours of sleep total. She was constantly distracted by hunger. Relicted some videos online of Army Ranger training, it's hard to believe human beings could survive those challenges. Get back up for love, all right! Ranger! All right!
绳子上跳进冷水中游泳，穿着全套制服。她被连续几个小时剥夺睡眠。她记得有一段九天的时间，她总共只睡了10个小时。她不断地被饥饿分散注意力。在网上看了一些陆军游骑兵训练的视频，很难相信人类能在那样的挑战中生存下来。为了爱，站起来，好吗！游骑兵！好吗！
All right! All this suffering had a purpose. To put trainees like Anastasia into a heart state, even though her instructor has called it something else. As far as ranger school goes, they like to use the term stress inoculation, so they create a lot of stress, and then they teach you how to live in that and how to cope with it. The stressors were both physical and psychological.
好吗！所有这些痛苦都有一个目的。将像阿纳斯塔西娅这样的学员置于“热状态”，尽管她的教官称之为别的东西。就游骑兵学校而言，他们喜欢使用“压力接种”这个词，所以他们制造大量的压力，然后教你如何在这种压力下生活，以及如何应对它。压力源既有生理上的，也有心理上的。
She was asked to oversee a dozen people in a simulated military mission. She had to organize a surprise attack. At first I was very nervous about it. She had to force herself to calm down and think through what needed to be done. I kind of learned how to take pieces of the task and effectively execute the pieces. And I could look at basically a five meter target instead of a 50 meter target.
她被要求在一次模拟军事任务中监督十几个人。她必须组织一次突袭。起初我对此非常紧张。她必须强迫自己冷静下来，思考需要做什么。我学会了如何将任务拆解并有效地执行这些部分。我可以基本上只看一个五米的目标，而不是50米的目标。
And I could take my little five meter targets. And I could very, very easily accomplish those tasks. She used simple tools, a notebook and pen, and made checklists. And then anytime that I'd start to feel kind of panicked or anxious because I was like, things aren't happening fast enough because everyone's tired. Or things aren't happening fast enough because people are distracted. I was able to look at my list and think about the things that I could check off or things that were going to be checked off soon.
我可以拿走我的小五米目标。我可以非常非常容易地完成这些任务。她使用了简单的工具，笔记本和笔，并制作了清单。然后，每当我开始感到恐慌或焦虑时，因为我觉得事情进展不够快，每个人都很累，或者因为人们分心而进展不够快，我就能看看我的清单，想想我可以勾掉的事情，或者很快就会被勾掉的事情。
And that really actually helped me relax because I knew that things were getting done and the more check marks I had on my list, the better I knew I was doing. Anastasia learned to control her behavior in different hot states, but it took weeks of round the clock training to get to that point. Few of us could handle what it takes to get our hungry, achy, exhausted selves to behave like our cold state selves. But not all challenges involve leading a team into battle. In civilian life, there can be less daunting ways to train yourself to respond to everyday challenges. Self-defense classes are designed to teach you
这实际上确实帮助我放松了，因为我知道事情正在完成，我在清单上打的勾越多，我就越知道自己做得越好。阿纳斯塔西娅学会了在不同的“热状态”下控制自己的行为，但这花了数周全天候的训练才达到那种程度。我们很少有人能处理好如何让饥饿、疼痛、精疲力竭的自己表现得像“冷状态”下的自己。但并非所有的挑战都涉及带领团队投入战斗。在平民生活中，有一些不那么令人生畏的方法可以训练自己应对日常挑战。自卫课程旨在教你
how to respond if you're attacked. Fire drills are designed to teach you to keep your head during an emergency. Julie Woodzica is developing a training program to help women respond to sexist comments and jokes. It's called fighting fire with fire. So, for instance, a guy tells a sexist joke and then the woman says, wow, still single, hum, Mark, which is funny, but the guy knows that like, oh, she don't like that. Every woman that you talk to can think of a time
如果受到攻击该如何反应。消防演习旨在教你在紧急情况下保持冷静。朱莉·伍兹卡正在开发一个培训项目，帮助女性应对性别歧视的评论和笑话。它被称为“以火攻火”。例如，一个男人讲了一个性别歧视的笑话，然后那个女人说：“哇，还是单身吗，嗯，马克？”这很有趣，但那个男人知道，“哦，她不喜欢那样。”你交谈过的每个女性都能想到一个时刻，
that they walked away from a situation where something sexist was said. And 10 minutes later, they think of the perfect comeback. I wish I had said this. And of course, in the moment, you don't think of it. So we're thinking if we can have a couple that are kind of in your back pocket, can you repeat you repeat that and hear you over my eyes rolling or just things that are, you know, easy to say and would apply to a lot of situations, maybe
她们在有人说了性别歧视的话时走开了。10分钟后，她们想到了完美的还击。我真希望我当时说了这个。当然，在那一刻，你不会想到它。所以我们在想，如果我们能有几个放在口袋里的备用方案，你能重复那个，听着我翻白眼，或者只是那些你知道的、容易说出口且适用于很多情况的话，也许
we can help women to confront in more subtle ways. Because it's hard. It's hard to tell people that they're being sexist. Julie thinks that in a better world, women wouldn't have this burden of devising comebacks. But for the moment, these one-liners give women tools. George Lowenstein says some hot-called situations are too challenging for us to manage as individuals. I think the solution is good public policy. Specifically he says public policy should make it easier for people in a heart state to make the same decisions they would otherwise choose in a court state.
我们可以帮助女性以更微妙的方式进行对峙。因为这很难。告诉别人他们有性别歧视很难。朱莉认为，在一个更好的世界里，女性不需要承担设计还击话语的负担。但目前，这些俏皮话给了女性工具。乔治·洛温斯坦说，有些热-冷情境对我们个人来说太具挑战性了。我认为解决方案是良好的公共政策。具体来说，他说公共政策应该让处于“热状态”的人更容易做出他们在“冷状态”下会选择的相同决定。
Condoms, he says, should be quickly and easily accessible. So, for example, condoms should be kind of ubiquitously available. In other cases, George believes that policy should be designed to slow down our actions. If I got really angry at someone I could just go down to Walmart and buy a gun today, that shouldn't be possible. When you combine the instant availability of guns and empathy gaps, That's a very toxic mixture. He also sees implications for our criminal justice system, where judges and juries determine how to treat people who have acted in hot states.
他说，避孕套应该能够快速且容易地获得。例如，避孕套应该随处可见。在其他情况下，乔治认为政策的设计应该旨在减缓我们的行动。如果我对某人非常生气，我今天就可以去沃尔玛买一把枪，这不应该成为可能。当你把枪支的即时可获得性和共情差距结合起来时，那是一种非常有毒的混合物。他还看到了这对我们刑事司法系统的影响，法官和陪审团在那里决定如何对待那些在“热状态”下行事的人。
Take drug addiction, for example. People who have never experienced drug craving, they are not going to have any understanding of how powerfully motivating it can be. I sometimes ask my students, suppose you were addicted to heroin, can you imagine ever abandoning your children or stealing from your parents? And everyone says, of course, I would never do that. But if they were addicted to heroin, it's very likely that they would do that. So in so many of these different situations like in the criminal justice system, it's so easy for people to condemn the behavior of people who are experiencing states that
以毒瘾为例。从未经历过毒瘾渴望的人，他们不会理解这种渴望有多么强大的驱动力。我有时会问我的学生，假设你对海洛因上瘾，你能想象自己会抛弃孩子或从父母那里偷钱吗？每个人都说，当然，我绝不会那样做。但如果他们对海洛因上瘾，他们很有可能会那样做。所以在刑事司法系统等许多不同的情况下，人们很容易谴责那些处于某种状态下的人的行为，而这些状态
they themselves are not experiencing when they make the judgment. We might need policy to constrain our decisions, but one thing we can do on our own is to be more compassionate when we're judging others and ourselves. Nina Fuller, the woman who can't let go after one night in the massage parlour half a century ago, doesn't consider herself judgmental of others. But for decades, she's had trouble extending such compassion to herself. I was ashamed that I wasn't a strong enough person. I said, no, I can't go. I got to do this.
他们在做出判断时自己并没有经历过。我们可能需要政策来约束我们的决定，但我们能自己做的一件事是，在评判他人和自己时更加富有同情心。尼娜·富勒，那个半个世纪前在按摩院度过一夜后无法释怀的女人，并不认为自己对他人评头论足。但几十年来，她一直难以对自己表现出这种同情。我为自己不够坚强而感到羞耻。我说，不，我不能去。我必须这样做。
You know, I was ashamed of that. The hot cold empathy gap makes other people feel more different from us than they actually are. When someone does something we can't imagine that we would do, it's easy to be judgmental. To conclude they are weak or worse that they are bad people. This gap also makes us feel extrangers to ourselves. So the next time we confidently announce that we would absolutely do this or we would never do that, we would be wise to remember that the people we are now are very different than the people we might become.
你知道，我为此感到羞耻。热-冷共情差距让其他人感觉比实际上与我们更不同。当某人做了我们无法想象自己会做的事情时，很容易去评判。断定他们软弱，或者更糟，断定他们是坏人。这种差距也让我们对自己感到陌生。所以下次当我们自信地宣布我们绝对会做这个或绝不会做那个时，我们最好记住，现在的我们与未来可能成为的我们是非常不同的。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Correll, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Special thanks to Doyle Dean, Ivory Keetley, Alex Curley and Rosanna Summers. Our unsung hero is NPR's Daniel Schuchin. Right around the time when we first published this episode, we were having some technical problems getting the episode out into the world.
《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、劳拉·科雷尔、克里斯汀·王、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。特别感谢多伊尔·迪恩、艾弗里·基特利、亚历克斯·柯利和罗珊娜·萨默斯。我们的无名英雄是NPR的丹尼尔·舒钦。就在我们首次发布这一集的时候，我们在将这一集发布到世界上时遇到了一些技术问题。
No matter what we tried, the audio didn't sound quite right when we tried to upload the episode. Daniel worked with us late into the evening to troubleshoot the problem. We're so grateful. For more ideas about human behavior, as well as brain teasers and moments of joy, be sure to check out our weekly newsletter. You can subscribe at news.hiddenbrain.org. That's N-E-W-S dot hiddenbrain dot org. Next week we continue our YouTube.no series with a look at how we can improve our marriages
无论我们尝试什么，当我们尝试上传这一集时，音频听起来都不太对劲。丹尼尔和我们一起工作到深夜来排查问题。我们非常感激。想要了解更多关于人类行为的想法，以及脑筋急转弯和快乐时刻，请务必查看我们的每周通讯。你可以在news.hiddenbrain.org订阅。那是N-E-W-S点hiddenbrain点org。下周我们将继续我们的YouTube.no系列，看看我们如何改善婚姻
by asking less of them. We have some control over the extent to which we interpret our partners in considerate or rude behavior in a way that's more generous and kind, and the kinder approach will make us happier in the relationship and our partner will probably be happier too. I'm Shankar Vedantin, see you soon. Oh, you know, I actually used the Amazon gift card. I bought a dress and the dress came and the dress was like so ugly. And in my head I was like, okay, that's karma for buying a bunch of stolen stuff. What did you do with the dress? I just have it. I just have it. Like all the other stuff I got from that guy, just sitting
通过对它们少一点要求。我们可以在一定程度上控制我们如何解读伴侣不体贴或粗鲁的行为，以一种更慷慨和友善的方式，而更友善的方法会让我们在关系中更快乐，我们的伴侣可能也会更快乐。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，很快再见。哦，你知道，我实际上用了亚马逊礼品卡。我买了一件连衣裙，裙子到了，裙子太丑了。在我的脑海里，我想，好吧，这就是买了一堆赃物的报应。你拿那件裙子怎么办了？我留着它。我只是留着它。就像我从那个家伙那里得到的其他所有东西一样，只是放在
in my house. You didn't return it to Amazon? No. Because I was like, I just serve, I just serve an ugly dress. Have you actually worn the ugly dress? No. That would be car make punishment if you had to wear it, don't you think? That's true, maybe I should wear it so that my karma is like completely satisfied.
我的房子里。你没有把它退给亚马逊吗？没有。因为我想，我只是应得的，我只是应得一件丑裙子。你真的穿过那件丑裙子吗？没有。如果你不得不穿它，那会是报应性的惩罚，你不觉得吗？那是真的，也许我应该穿上它，这样我的报应就完全满足了。
No, that would be carmic punishment if you had to wear it, don't you think? That's true, maybe I should wear it so that my carma is like completely satisfied. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不，如果你不得不穿它，那会是报应性的惩罚，你不觉得吗？那是真的，也许我应该穿上它，这样我的报应就完全满足了。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。